(audience applauds)
- So I'm such a fan.
You look gorgeous.
I've been a fan since like,
you probably hate this.
It's like everybody sings
"Since You've Been Gone" to me.
But like Percy Jackson days,
like, I have loved you since.
- I love that.
- Okay. Okay.
- No, I love that people
still love Percy Jackson.
- Yeah. Well I also have kids now too
so now we're like revamping it all.
But last year you got married, right?
- Yes.
- Yes!
Did everything go as
planned or was anything.
- Yeah, I mean most of it went as planned.
I tried to, you know, we
did the best we could.
We had a wedding planner,
but you know, like life.
- Yep.
- Things happen and you have
to sort of go with the flow.
- Yeah.
- I mean there was an
issue with the bus that was
supposed to take everyone
from the hotel to the venue
which was less than a mile, by the way.
So they could have walked and
it would've been less problematic,
but it hit a curb, then hit another curb.
- What?
- Got lost.
- Was everyone Okay?
- Got lost and it was a mile away.
- And then tried to drop everyone off
in the middle of nowhere.
- Was the driver inebriated? (laughs)
- No.
- Like, I was like , wait.
- No, I think maybe there was a wrong.
- Miscommunication.
- Yes.
- I don't wanna throw
anyone under the bus,
so to speak.
- Yeah, on TV.
(audience laughs)
- That's right.
But it was, it ended up being fine but,
no one really wanted to bring it up to me.
But then of course my best
friend was like, "Oh my God
it was a disaster."
- Yeah. (laughs)
- We were all on the side of
the road and we were like,
"We don't think this is it."
But then you just sort
of go with the flow and,
not take it too seriously.
- It looked magical, I saw the
pictures, it looked magical.
And that flower thing behind you.
The wall of beauty.
- Beautiful.
- Yeah, and that's so cute.
You're such a handsome couple anyway.
- Yeah.
- So what do you plan to do, this year,
to take care of yourself
maybe just a little better?
Do better at?
- I mean, I always, I'm
obsessed with acupuncture.
I do that a ton.
- I love acupuncture.
- To the point where I probably should
have, like, an affair with an
acupuncturist to save money.
- 'Cause you spend so much money. (laughs)
- That's right.
- I used to make fun of it.
I dunno how my husband would feel about.
- No, but I used to make fun of it.
But it really, it truly, like, healed.
This thing I had going on with my foot.
They said I was gonna have to have surgery
and I was like, "What?"
And then like all of a sudden it healed.
It's real.
It's true.
- It is.
- Yes.
- And I, go sometimes
three, four times a week.
Which is so.
- Oh my gosh.
- It's my addiction.
- It does make you feel really good.
- Yes.
- It is a certain kind
of high, I will say that.
- Yeah.
- And I think it's a good opportunity.
- It's a healthy addiction.
- Yeah, I mean, if you're
constantly on your phone
and you have so much going on and even
if it's just an opportunity
to lie there and,
sort of meditate or do nothing
and just be by yourself.
So, that's nice.
- You have to nothing.
There's a bunch of needles in you.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Yes, exactly.
You can't move.
- Yeah, I'm with you on that.
Okay, so I'm told you
recently went, is it to Paris?
- [Kelly] Is that where you were?
- [Alexandra] Yes.
- [Kelly] I love Paris.
Did you love it?
- I love Paris.
- Yeah.
I will, say I'm not, you know
how everybody's like, "Paris."
I'm not that about it, but I liked it.
I thought it was cool.
- Well, the Eiffel Tower
- It's beautiful.
- I mean if you like go.
- I just think everybody sets it up.
- Well, there's a problem, right?
When you set something up to be like.
- Yeah.
When everyone says, "Oh
my God, you have to go."
"It's the most amazing place on Earth."
And then you have, I don't know what.
You have these expectations
that it's gonna be.
- Yeah.
- And then it's just a city I guess.
- I know!
And then I'm like, Paris is amazing.
- A great city.
- By the way, Paris is amazing.
But so is the rest of France.
Like, the rest of France is beautiful.
- Well, the south of France
is, France is beautiful.
Yeah.
- Europe in general is gorgeous.
- Yeah, were you working
or was it for play?
- Little bit of both.
- Oh, okay.
- I go do the fashion stuff.
- Yes.
So have you ever had any
big fails while traveling?
'Cause you like to travel.
- I love to travel.
Yeah, I've been really lucky.
I mean, when I was younger, I
don't do it now as much, but
I used to just sort of,
when I was in Europe,
jump on the train and and go.
I would just go and see what I could
find out in the country.
- That's fun.
I was in Germany once
and I was in Berlin and
I jumped on the train and I
went out to the countryside
and I got lost.
But I was somewhere where
no one spoke English and
I do not speak German.
And so then I started to sort of panic and
I was young enough that I couldn't really
control my emotions.
- Yeah.
- And I just start sobbing.
And these, like, very nice people were
speaking to me in German,
like, "Are you okay?"
And we couldn't communicate.
- Sad little American girl.
- Yeah, it was very embarrassing.
And I had to pull myself together and
finally I found the right train.
But it was like this,
you know when you're traveling
you get overwhelmed and you.
- Yeah.
- But, but going alone and
traveling like that is cool.
That's brave.
- Yeah, it's very cool, yeah.
Except the people thought
I was a complete weirdo.
I was being very dramatic
over probably nothing.
- No, I would've gotten scared, I would.
I believe in the buddy system though.
- I was somehow scared for no reason.
- I saw too many "Dateline" specials.
I believe in a buddy system. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
If I'm going down, I'm taking
a buddy with me. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
It's like, that's my system.
So your new show is
called "Mayfair Witches."
So could you tell us a little about it?
- It's about a girl.
She's a doctor surgeon and she finds out
that she is a witch.
And that she belongs
to a different family.
She was adopted and she
finds out that she's actually
part of this family
called the, the Mayfairs.
And it's quite amazing
to do a role like this
'cause it really is sort
of a metaphor for life.
Like when you're going
through huge transitions
how do you handle it?
- Yeah.
- Only this person's
transition is, you know,
that she has these powers.
And how do you control them and all that.
- Which is fun.
- It's great fun.
I love that kind of escapism.
- Yeah.
- That's fun.
So ever experienced anything
supernatural like in your life?
- I haven't personally.
I do think there's some
things that are like,
"Is that a coincidence or how did that?"
There's a lot of magic
in the world in that way.
- Yeah.
But there was one time
I was shooting a film
in Louisiana and I was in a little town
outside of place called Shreveport.
And one of the members of
the crew, a girl, starts
crying outside of the
house we were shooting in.
And she said, "I can't."
"I can't go in there."
"There's a woman in the corner of the room
saying, 'What are you
all doing in my house?'"
"Get out of my house."
And she said, "I can't go in there."
And she wouldn't come into work.
And then later that day we
all found out the husband,
the owner of the house said,
"My wife passed away in that room."
- What?
- And there was no way
for her to know about it.
But I didn't see the ghost.
- Oh, lucky.
- But that always creeps
me out 'cause I've never
found an explanation for it.
- Yeah, no, I don't wanna, I always,
I just speak out like,
"Please don't show yourself
to me 'cause I will die."
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, I think it's.
- I'll join you. (laughs)
- All the ghosts are being nice to us.
They're like, they can't handle it.
- Yeah, just live your life wherever I am.
Fine, don't show me you.
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
Congrats though on everything.
- Thank you.
- I literally, I was late to the game on
getting to watch "White Lotus."
Congrats on it because
I, literally, got sick
for like three weeks, it felt like.
And I was like, "Oh my God."
"I've never gotten to
watch this whole thing."
I watched the whole thing
like back to back to back.
It was so good, so talented.
Do you feel like, 'cause
I've known you for a while,
I feel like, since you were little,
and so I've been watching
you for a minute.
But some people are like,
"Oh my God, she's amazing."
And just discovering you.
Do you feel like it's been a
long road to have that moment?
Like a "White Lotus" moment?
- Yeah, I mean, I think I've had
a lot of ups and downs in
my career, like anyone.
I mean, this career is you've probably.
- Oh, music.
- I mean, you're amazing.
- Oh no, I think every
career has ebbs and flows.
- And yeah, it's a little
bit of ups and downs and
so I feel, in a way, like I've been
discovered over and over and over.
- It's kind of cool
- Sort of.
But, there's always that, and I think,
with the Emmy nomination
with "White Lotus," you know
it's sort of like
overnight being discovered.
- But you've been doing it forever, yeah.
But you've been doing it for 20 years.
So I just think it's about
doing what you love and
doing it for the right reasons.
And, and then, you know,
hopefully it all works out.
But it's been really special for me.
I feel really lucky.
- Yeah, it is funny though
when you said, sort of.
I was like, yeah, that's kind
of like when I go somewhere
and I sing somewhere and they're like,
"Oh my, you're a good singer."
And I'm like, "Ah, okay."
(audience laughs)
(Alexandra laughs)
- Like, it's been a minute, but all right.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, or they're like, "Oh
wow, Alex is a good actress?"
- Or like, "Do you have an a record?"
"Do you have a record?"
And I'm like, well, and
then, like, alright. (laughs)
But it's like, it's one
of those things where
you do, you feel like you've been working,
but sometimes people do,
they're just discovering you.
For whatever reason they
haven't seen, or whatever,
or heard or whatever.
- Yeah.
It is kind of cool though.
I think in the sense of
like, you have time to
really create who you are and
who you wanna be publicly.
And you're not, like,
right off the bat known for
just one thing and you're
kind of beholden to that.
So that's kind of cool.
- Yeah, it's very cool.
And I think also I'm getting,
you know, as you get older
there's whole new generations
of people sort of.
- Yeah.
- Learning who you are and just, and.
- Especially with streaming.
- Yeah.
And you get to sort of
recreate your career yourself.
- [Kelly] That's fun.
- But I don't, I've just been lucky.
- Yeah.
- I don't put that much.
And I, "White Lotus", I was so lucky.
- Yeah.
- What a cool show to be part of.
- So you worked as a bartender
when you were coming up.
- So.
- [Alexandra] Yes.
- Were you good at it?
- I became very good.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- Yeah.
I was a horrible waitress,
so I was like, well
I wanna be a bartender.
And everyone was like, "Okay,
let this girl go bartend."
And then I mastered it at the time.
- We're talking like, Tom
Cruise cocktail, you mastered?
- Oh, I'd, like, pick up five bottles and
I would show off and I would.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I was like so quick.
I was the fastest bartender and
I was always trying to
get faster and faster.
- You are competitive
with yourself. (laughing)
- Only with chess and bartending.
- Okay.
(audience laughs)
- Okay, I wanna see this.
Can we see this?
I heard about your skill.
(audience applause)
- I haven't done it in 10 years.
- I don't care.
(audience cheers)
- Oh my God.
- I wanna see it.
Thank you guys.
- You're very welcome.
- Look at it, we just gonna bar.
- Thank you so much.
- I love this job.
They just roll out bars
when you ask for them.
It's awesome.
- I need this in my house.
- Okay, I'm gonna step back just in case.
You said it's been a minute, so.
- All right. Yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
- Do we have people ready
to clean up the glass?
So what do you, so
yeah, show me something.
- ♪ Show me somethin' good, ♪
- I'm like wanting to do five bottles,
but I think that might be dangerous.
- Oh my God, are you
serious with this right now?
(Kelly gasps)
(audience cheers)
You just like you, were you?
(audience cheers and applauds)
- That's not that impressive.
- You, wait, were you ever
flipping or doing anything like?
I wanna taste whatever you just did.
What is that?
Well that's a lot of
different drinks right now.
We're about to.
- I think this is a Long Island Iced Tea.
- Okay, okay.
You're like, "I think?" (laughs)
- Oh, I don't know if it's gonna be good.
- I don't care.
I'll try it.
- We'll see.
- My bar is low. (laughs)
- Oh, see that's the part I forgot.
- Here, we'll do it like this.
- Well, 'cause there's
no, like, strainer for it.
Yeah, there's nothing.
- There we go.
- I'm gonna try it.
(ice clinks)
- Okay. Try it.
- Okay, with a little lemon.
- [Alexandra] Yeah, you
can make it look better.
- Yeah, make it fancy.
Look at that.
See. Hey.
Okay, here we go.
- No one would hire me anymore.
- Well, I think you're busy.
(audience laughs)
- (laughs)I think you're doing all right.
Wait, here we go.
- Cheers.
Here we go.
(audience applauds)
- Great.
- Not that bad.
- Yeah.
- Happy New Year, y'all.
Cheers!
- Happy New Year!